Konami will reportedly be at E3 this
year in a big way according to Andy
Robinson via the VGC podcast the world's
Premier makers of pachinko machines May
steal the show at the long absent trade
event with the new Castlevania game and
a remake of Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake
Eater in terms of the other older metal
gear solid games potentially being
playable on Modern platforms Robinson
said that as of one year or two years
ago being able to do so in some shape or
form was in the cards but it's now less
clear what the situation is quote I
would imagine that the Metal Gear Solid
3 remake is going to be somewhat of a
test bed for that Robinson said Robinson
also noted how Konami is quote opening
up to collaborating with more developers
though it wasn't clear if he was just
talking about the Silent Hill series or
konami's wider portfolio as well some
kind of Metal Gear Solid 3 remake has
been rumored for a long while now but
there's been no official comment from
Konami on the matter last October the
also long rumored and repeatedly leaked
Silent Hill 2 remake was revealed which
is being developed by layers of fear
Studio bloopa team it's been nearly 10
years since the last release of a new
Castlevania game that wasn't either a
Pachinko machine or mobile type and if
we're being honest it's been much much
longer than that since the last truly
good Castlevania game came out with the
success of the extremely excellent
Netflix animated series you have to
imagine Konami would be looking to
resurrect the Beloved franchise and have
it be more successful than the
inconsistent Lords of Shadow reboot of
the early 2010s as for Metal Gear Solid
3 Snake Eater while initially you think
it would make more sense to remake the
first game in the franchise first Snake
Eater is the actual first title
chronologically telling the story of
naked snake aka Big Boss the character
that Solid Snake from metal gears 1 2
and 4 is a clone of if you're new to the
metal gear franchise and that sounds
confusing to you you have just hit the
tippiest tip of the convolution iceberg
when it comes to this series so Konami
could potentially be trying to mitigate
as much of that as possible by releasing
the remakes in chronological order this
way too they could potentially point to
the still very modern Metal Gear Solid 5
the phantom pain which is the next game
in the series chronologically as the
next game to jump to for people that
pick up Snake Eater giving them more
time to remake Metal Gear Solid one fun
fact about me and Snake Eater before I
moved to the United States as a kid my
family and I visited a couple months
earlier to look at schools and houses
which is when I excitedly picked up
Metal Gear Solid 3 a game that had not
released in England yet at that time to
take back with me this was also sadly my
first lesson in what a region locked
console was those were Dark Times
if you're excited at the idea of a new
Castlevania Game releasing you're
probably curious about the franchise's
DLC tie-in with roguelike dead cells
alongside a brand new look at the latest
DLC the game's developer motion twin
reveals that players will be able to
play as Rick to Belmont in the Richter
mode which lets them take control of the
iconic Castlevania character the mode is
only available in a secret level located
somewhere deep inside Dracula's castle
and will feature Richter's classic move
set inspired by Castlevania Symphony of
the Night the Gameplay trailer also
confirms there will be a boss fight
against Medusa and other enemy types
that players will uncover throughout the
exploration of Castle Dracula dead cells
return to Castlevania is set to launch
on March 6th for PC PlayStation 4 and 5
Xbox One and Series S and x what are you
more excited for a Metal Gear Solid 3
reboot or a new Castlevania Game let me
know in the comments below and we'll see
you here for more Gamespot news
[Music]